i remember
when i was young
i could not talk to girls i just felt
embarrassed there was oh i couldn't talk
to girls that i liked
that was the toughest part um
i was just afraid you know i just had
this thing built in my head that they
hated me or that they just did not like
me and i remember one time
this girl i was just in love with as a
child i remember
that i spit in her hair um
because i was so pent up with
wanting to just
tell her that i liked her maybe or
something that i couldn't so i just
gathered every bit of genetic ability
liquid ability in my face
and just deposited on onto her head one
time
um and i ended up getting suspended for
that dude i went through a time where i
was so nervous to talk to women
the only thing i could use were like
shitty pickup lines you know garbage
ones um you know they had the one are
you a polar uh
are you a polar bear because you just
you know i'm a polar bear i'm about to
break the ice you know that garbage
you know verbal
and then
i used to have this one line
in hindsight this is horrible
i was like uh let's play hiroshima
i'll lay on my back and you blow the
out of me
so that was
but i mean that's where i was
i was at a point where
personally
i couldn't
find a comfort level where i could speak
to women
and how to get through that
i would find you gotta you have to you
have to get through it and you're gonna
have to practice
and what i would practice is listening
i'd practice listening man i think
you're you you could be thinking because
i personally used to think that i had to
start the conversation every time
sometimes you can just listen
just listen
i mean a lot of women all they want is a
man to listen to him and to care and i
think if you start with that with the
listening
then you'll eventually find spots where
you can
interject and offer
um offer something to the conversation
you know
and also
if you're it's it's
and you can just try things also if you
want to try little things to talk to a
woman
i would try little things like
i like what kind of candy do you like
you know that like a five-year-old
would say because
all it's about is starting the
conversation
you don't need to think or worry three
or four steps in advance
just say hello my name is
so-and-so you know
um just little things like that are
really the starters
uh and we got you got you have to get
your self-confidence up
because if you are thinking that women
don't like you then they're just gonna
sense that you know um
because the thing is they probably do
like you you know they probably do
and you just have to find some ways to
be comfortable around them
so comfortability will lead to
communication
so if you can get to being comfortable
you're going to be in a good spot
now
you also man if you get hooked up on the
drugs and that you're going to start
weaning yourself off of that you know if
the only way you can speak to women is
on at a rave on ecstasy
dude you might
that might not end well you know so i
don't know if you need to put on some
house music and suck on a claritin or
something at the house
you know or start to wean yourself off
of that behavior
so you can create some regular behaviors
where you're actually you know
communicating to women in a regular way
man
you know when you can find a girl that
you already know
and it doesn't have to be one that
you're sexually interested in
and just communicate just listen
practice bro you know practice
and also you don't want to be in a spot
where
where you just take any girl that will
take you
and you know for years i spent time in
that place
where i would just
any girl that would take me
i would accept you know i would take
even if she didn't have
some of my values or qualities or
anything
i just felt
so
less of myself and i'm not saying that
you feel this way about you
but i felt so less of myself
that i just felt like
i wasn't worthy of someone
who was good for me or who i was good
for i was just hopefully
worthy
of anyone
and that was not a fun place to be
and uh and you end up with people that
you end up with being in a match that's
not a real match you know because you
want to end up if you want to end up
with a woman and if you're looking for
something long-term
you're going to want to find a woman
that's real
and if you don't always have to agree
with girls you know if they don't have
your vibe dude then screw them on to the
next one you know um
but just don't make your do if you can
get in your head
that you have value
and you have worth which you do you do
bruh you know you sound like a pretty
legit dude man i'd probably go party
with you bro
you know i'd probably do a couple bumps
and put on a wig and let you practice
conversation on me you know
um
but you don't want to end up with
someone who doesn't deserve you just
because you're afraid to
to
you're afraid to feel
like someone does deserve you
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you